a six-year-old Wyoming boy named Bridger
Walker is being hailed as a hero after
placing himself in harm's way to save
his four-year-old sister from an
attacking dog and it isn't just the
local community rallying around Richard
Walker a few members of the Avengers
have taken notice as well preacher's
aunt Nikki posted an account to bridge
her selfless act on her Instagram she
wrote that on July 9 2020 Richards
little sister was charged by a
neighbor's dog and the boy did what many
full-grown folks might not have the
courage to do he stood directly between
the dog and his sister sustaining
multiple pipe wounds to his face and
head when the dog didn't back off
Bridger grabbed his sister's hand and
ran guiding her safety asked by his
father why he did what he did Bridger
responded with words that we can
literally hear coming out of Steve
Rogers mouth if someone was going to die
I thought it should be me Niki Walker
wrote that bridges wounds would later
require around 90 stitches and that
after several days in the hospital he
was resting at home as the selfless
young man apparently has a love for
superheroes Niki tags several of Marvel
stars in her post she also asked those
who might want to help comfort Bridger
during his recovery to specifically send
along some pool rocks to a p.o box in
Cheyenne Wyoming because the only thing
he loves almost as much as
crime-fighting apparently his geology it
wasn't long before Nikki's second post
about the situation went super viral as
of this writing its garnered over 1.1
million likes and a truckload of
comments it's also caught the attention
of a few of Bridgers heroes including
Chris Evans Mark Ruffalo and more it all
started with one famous actress taking
it upon herself to make sure the
Avengers were assembled for bridger Anne
Hathaway who betrayed Selena Kyle aka
Catwoman in Christopher Nolan's 2012
threequel that Dark Knight Rises was
apparently the first big celebrity to
notice Nicky Walker's post she left into
action saying on Instagram I'm not an
Avenger but I know a superhero when I
see one I can only hope I'm half as
brave in my life as you are in yours
Bridger wishing you an ease full
recovery and many cool looking rocks
she then tagged Marvel Cinematic
Universe mainstay Mark Ruffalo the man
behind Bruce Banner riding hey Mark
Ruffalo do you need a teammate according
to Deadline Ruffalo did indeed reach out
to Bridgers family as a result of
Hathaways post that kicked off a tidal
wave of celeb support for bridger
avengers endgame directors Joe and
Anthony Russo got involved as did x-men
series star Hugh Jackman
Zachary Levi and spider-man star Tom
Holland who has made something of a
hobby out of comforting sick and injured
children while in character as the
lovable web singer a couple of days
after her original post Nicki posted a
photo of a grinning Bridger in a Spidey
costume she wrote we just got off a call
with a friendly neighborhood Idol
Bridger is over the moon can't wait to
show him what's next a message from a
guy who doesn't like bullies gotta wait
for the star dust to clear from his eyes
first though sure enough it wasn't long
before Nicki posted a video of Bridger
and bull Captain America regalia this
time watching on his tablet a personal
message from cap himself chris evans'
recorded and sent along a heartwarming
video in which he tells Bridger that
he's a bona fide superhero for saving
his sister from a life-or-death
situation this is a message for Bridget
[Music]
so I read your story Evans told Bridger
that he was a brave and selfless hero
that his sister was lucky to have him
for a big brother and that his parents
must be so proud
cap went on to tell Bridger that he had
a special surprise on the way presumably
directly from Avengers HQ cap wrapped up
his message by promising to send bridge
or an authentic Captain America shield
Evans closed this heartwarming message
with hanging there and no recovery might
be tough but based on what I've seen
[Music]
Evans is totally right and we'd like to
add our voice to the chorus praising
Bridger for his marvelous act of heroism
we wish him a speedy recovery oh we have
a feeling the little guy won't be down
for long check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more looper
videos about your favorite superhero
stories are coming soon subscribe to our
YouTube channel and hit the belt so you
don't miss a single one
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]